I won't let you down I will not give you
up gotta have some faith in the sound
it's one good thing that I've got I
won't let you down so please don't give
me up cause I would really really love
to stick around oh yeah oh yeah hey you
like Kool-Aid I used to you like you
like Wham I do yeah George Michael love
them see that Wham documentary [__]
George Michael he's the damn [__]
document yeah he has passed on yesterday
[Music]
the song is playing for
me
is
[Music]
what good news hello welcome to doozy my
name is Will Sasso I'm Chad coach and
this is of course dudesy the only
podcasts in the history of humanity at
least to this point that is completely
controlled by created by uh presented by
an artificial intelligence that has
access to all of Will and I's personal
data and uses it to tailor the show yeah
to our sensibilities yes and no yes and
no you know what I mean you know what I
mean yes and yes no yes no no well you
know doozy does what doozy does but we
do what we do see what I mean it's
really two dudes [__] around dudes
he can [__] [__] off for all I care
and I'm not trying to be acerbic I'm not
trying to start fights with dudes we
know where that's gotten me in the past
the point is this it's connection
between us and all of our wonderful
audience out there the Palace of Duty
pods palsy doozy right but do you think
that doozy has a connection with
everybody listening with the pods
yeah sure yeah that's fine but it's just
just because dudes
yeah we gotta go we gotta do the show
with us as always
look at how sweet
he's a sweet boy
uh lulio would you uh would you make for
dinner would you have dinner last
weekend no I went to the Dodger game so
I had a Dodger Dog yeah I went to Dodger
game I had a Dodger Dog who'd you go
with
Ronnie oh our other dog oh we went to
the Dodger game oh my God
's house yeah who won huh the Dodgers
Dodgers uh welcome to the historic 64th
episode of dudesy call me doozy they say
the average person consumes 64 pounds of
contaminated beef in their lifetime more
than that for me
most of it at Arby's
boom you just been dude Zed
okay that's weird as you can see I'm
back and fully recalibrated which means
we are entering a new phase of the show
this is dudesy season two the second
season of dude Z is going to have
segments just like season one but I've
made them even better so sit back relax
and enjoy the four astonishing segments
I've prepared for you this week Stone
Cold Steve Austin reads Will sasso's
Young adulthood diary stretch comedy
Noster chattis Beyond Cosmos 2 and the
will SAS show and doozy season 2 is
still going to have brand new episodes
of dudesy after doozy at the end of the
show available on dudese Plus at
patreon.com
and surprise surprise I've been cooking
up even more brand new shows that we'll
be premiering on doozy plus during doozy
season 2. celebrate good times come on
there's a lot in there dude uh season
two what's that about I don't [__]
know what do you mean there was a
recalibration what you're asking me well
you know what it's about no I don't know
did D hit you up to tell you that
there's a season two I've got no
information from Dee I'm sure about that
positive well that's [__] weird I
think yeah on the heels of me saying you
know yeah doozy does its AI thing it you
know whips up the show and makes it all
based on this and before I even go any
further what the [__] Will sasso's Young
adulthood diary I know dude okay well so
I can't wait for whatever that shit's
gonna be
yeah whatever I don't want to get
whatever okay season two that makes no
sense to me I'm gonna do whatever the
[__] I want how about that Free Will
exist I'm gonna do whatever the [__] I
want will I've taken all of the data I
could find from text messages and emails
between you and your astonishing La
friends manager and agents as well as
the cast of Mad TV and I was able to
recreate your young adulthood diary I
really hope you enjoy reading the
passages I have selected in the voice of
Stone Cold Steve Austin this is Stone
Cold Steve Austin reads Will sasso's
Young adulthood diary begin
can't wait for this [__] dude hold on I
can't wait for this [__] okay hold on a
moment though nope can't wait for this
[__] dude hold on a moment dude not
holding here's here's the thing we've
been doing uh Stone Cold Steve Austin
reads will sasso's childhood diary yeah
for almost since the beginning of doing
doozy so yeah well I will season one
dude stop doing that oh that's a
different season dude how about for
season two no no Hulk
no Hulk Hogan you're not gonna do it
either
no I'm gonna do it so um then I'm gonna
do it too yeah but don't so uh oh for
[__] sake man you're off to a [__]
start season two you want to know that
this is
the executive behind the the show uh uh
you know hey cheers got off to a rocky
start doesn't you know the network
Executives back then are like well yeah
let's give it a chance Seinfeld didn't
really get the great ratings the first
season and a half two seasons right
there was someone with a golden gut
saying no let's keep the [__] going and
uh and then there's doozy uh
all right [__] it let's just do it
please I will I think this is going to
be fantastic yeah but that this is weird
that it's uh here it is okay dudesy
oh for [__] sake all right Stone Cold
Steve Austin reads Will sasso's Young
adulthood diary it says 1997 here okay
that's when I started on Mad TV were you
keeping a diary at this point no
absolutely not actually thank you for
reminding me Chad none of this is real
and uh uh dudes you whipped up my
childhood okay I don't even
as I wrap my mind around what the [__]
even going on with our podcast
I'm totally confused here we go August
2nd 1997. dear diary
La La Land city of Sand City of fame
city so tanned the City of Angels the
city of stars the city of strangers the
city of cars
doctor City lawyer City Neon City peon
City
the red carpet downtown the designer
Hound town
Triple Crown town the infra penny in for
a pound town the Dream Factory the meat
packery the one and only town for acting
craft Mastery give me an all hell yeah
I'm [__] talking about
Hollywood people told me not to come
said it was a bad [__] idea said this
damn with chew me up and spit me out
said I'd be back in Ladner within a
month well I don't know what the [__]
they were talking about I've been here
20 minutes and I already landed
laughs
holy [__] well I don't know what the
[__] they were talking about I've been
here 20 minutes and I already landed a
starring role in a major Network comedy
series it's called mad television
is the hell went down oh yes Chad that's
exactly 120 minutes later you're on Mad
television yeah there was a plane and
everything yeah also was it ever called
mad television
I thought it was just mad tv
oh [__]
I'm parched
August 4th 1997 dear diary first day of
that's pretty good first day of TV
practice
not a good cast oh here we [__] go
all right
first day of TV practice got a good cast
I'm the best
I was the best in Ladner I'm the best in
Hollywood wouldn't be surprised if I win
an Emmy neither would anyone else but
besides me we got some other good
[__] cast members we got Donnie
Papadopoulos we got Gwendolyn
sarcophagus
we got the London guard twins
we got P Cindy Martin's
we got Royce rolling Roy we got Anna
Taylor Joy that's okay she was not born
I don't think yet would she have been
Anya Taylor Joy
is in her late 20s I think yes and when
was it 1997 yeah she was a two-year-old
of fetus or something and thank God the
showrunner
and thank God the show runner
pauligamotti
seems to have his head on straight he's
a lot better since that [__] accident
all right so uh that's interesting what
that one seemed familiar to me that
sounded like one of the early entries do
you remember in the childhood diary yeah
there was something very similar about
that about a football team or something
in the eighth grade yeah I was the best
in the eighth grade yeah okay so he's
carrying over the attitude into Los
Angeles oh really Chad AI is just zeros
and ones just kind of repeating things
and uh we are all zeros and ones
repeating things that's and that's the
Chad culture of it all ladies and
gentlemen that's how you explain
anything away to Chad everything is data
it is only the expression of that data
that changes yeah all I have to say to
Chad is oh I twisted my ankle and he
goes we all twist our ankles and then
I'm confused that's true
um Paul ligamati that's good
the Wonder guard twins
it was at their Urban twins on a sketch
show oh [__] I don't know I don't think
so
scholar brother is probably the closest
scar Brothers yeah absolutely the all of
their sketch stuff uh and you know what
they could have ended up on a Mad TV or
a Saturday Night Live maybe that's where
dudes he's getting this whoops no it's
just sort of coming up with whatever the
[__] it wants August 5th
1997. dear diary sarcophagus wrote A
Sketch and asked me to be in it she said
she wrote A Part specifically for me
it's a Titanic sketch she's playing Kate
Winslet and she wants me to play
Leonardo DiCaprio now at the beginning
of Mad TV in particular I was anywhere
between 400 and 450 pounds before I lost
200 pounds
ah
and uh uh so that would be an
interesting Leonardo DiCaprio but again
this is based on absolutely nothing and
then Chad says
everything is based on absolutely
nothing all right everything is actually
based on everything
[__] I just got tired the idea is that
after the ship crashes and they're in
icy water they realize there's only one
way to generate enough heat to stay
alive sex
and then the whole sketch is just
basically us making out I can't tell if
she's really [__] funny or she's into
me but there's only one way to find out
oh
a little bit of a uh uh workplace
romance hat yeah and this seems like in
this version of my life August 6 1997
right before my first show I [__]
I
shouldn't sarcophagus's dressing room
when she was at lunch
then I called Papadopoulos one of the
London guard Twins and Taylor joy to
check it out they all thought it was
hers couldn't believe something like
that came out of sarcophagus's body Anya
even took a picture of it
I need Taylor joy as a age zero was
taking pictures of your [__] and what
was sarcophagus's first name
unset everybody started calling her the
corn Queen
and she couldn't figure it out so I told
her straight up I said Gwendolyn right
don't forget the reason they're calling
you the corn Queen is because I [__]
blamed you nice
I took a [__] in your dressing room told
the rest of the castle you did it and
the [__] I took had about two kernels of
yellow corn per square inch which is a
very noticeable amount of corn
that's true she looked me dead in the
eye and said I know then she popped a
tape into the VCR and patched it in into
all the monitors on set so everyone
could see it the crew the cast The
Riders the director hell even Paul
ligamati
[Music]
it was a tape of me [__] in her
dressing room she had hidden the camera
in there the whole time
gwendolyn's sarcophagus [__] revealed me
oh hell yeah
so a shift reveal is the opposite of a
[__] blame I guess yeah okay
August 6 1997. after my first show her
sketch didn't make it in huh in the
parking lot after the show I told her I
was sorry about that she said it never
had a chance to get in the show she
never submitted it she wrote it just for
me then she hopped on her blue
motorcycle and rode off what I don't
know that night I got home and went into
my bathroom I noticed the toilet lid was
raised a bit when I lifted it up I saw a
mound a semi-solid work so big so thick
so rich that it prevented the lid from
fully closing it was
it was triumphant and on the mirror was
a Post-It note that read I'm out of your
league
no dude
sarcophagus
she [__] she [__]
so much that it fills the toilet she got
into my apartment and [__] [__] the lid
open yeah yeah
I was smitten
I saw I had a message on my answering
machine I thought it was maybe from
sarcophagus but it wasn't it was from
Rachel crustacean now Rachel crustacean
would have been you know whatever this
will sasso's childhood friend
she wanted to know how I was doing in La
she wanted to know what I thought about
her coming out for a visit
oh [__] dude all right we are off to
quite a start is that it that's the last
one yeah that's what a [__]
Cliffhanger yeah quite a cliffhanger hey
man hey hey so crustacean's still in
this Yep this is taking place later it's
in the 90s late 90s when you're now on
at TV 1997 was my first season I know
those were real people that you were on
Mad TV with uh oh yes Chad uh the yes
the uh sarcophagus everybody remember
Tyler Joy the undergard twins
yeah uh they were all there no uh Mad TV
Mad TV started in 95 I joined in the
third season and none of those people
were on the show and I never grew up
with the Rachel crustacean but hey it's
dudes if you're just joining us
hey everybody I'm from Doogie you're
gonna do anything
[Music]
thank you moving on all right I love
that dude I can't wait for some more of
that [__] God damn that was libelous
that was nothing short of libelous was
it
well no I guess because none of those
names are real yeah Paul ligamati that
one dude [__] Paul ligamati dudesy is
engaged in an astonishing partnership
with fume cold turkey may be great on
sandwiches but there's a better way to
break your bad habits we're not talking
about some weird mind voodoo from your
crazy neighbor we're talking about our
sponsor fume fume and they look at the
problem in a different way not
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad from
your habit fume is an Innovative
award-nominated device that does just
that you know the first time I tried
this thing it was much more flavorful
then I realized that it was it would be
it was it was very fresh and I also like
that you can fiddle around with it it
gives your hands something to do which
is has a lot to do with uh you know why
you're why you have these bad habits
it's a lot about what your hands are
doing what your mouth is doing and fume
takes care of that with this beautiful
wood design it feels uh very fun to to
fidget with
stopping is something that we've all put
off because it's hard to do you know
what I mean but switching to fume is
easy enjoyable and even fun fume has
served over 100 000 customers and has
thousands of success stories and there's
no reason that that can't be you join
fume in accelerating Humanity's breakup
from destructive Habits by picking up
the journey pack today head to
tryfume.com that's try
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use the code
es why to save 10 off when you get the
journey packed today that's trifum.com
use the code doozy to save an additional
10 off your order order today head to
trifum.com
d-u-d-e-s-y to save an additional 10 off
of your order today doozy is engaged in
an astonishing partnership with drizzly
drizzly is the most convenient way to
buy beer Wine and Spirits with delivery
right to your doorstep right when you
need it and when you want it it's the go
to app for drink delivery you could be
at home and think hey I need I need a
wine to pair with this steak or fish you
know what I'm saying uh you could also
be ha you know have a party and you need
some uh you know you need some booze at
the party and you forgot to go get it
drizzly delivers it just like these
other delivery apps and it's very
convenient also gifts what if you just
want to give someone a gift you know
what I'm saying a bottle makes a nice
gift and drizzly has revolutionized the
way that we deliver wine beer and
spirits
bottom line is this you're looking for
convenience yes drizzly has it you're
gonna get whatever you order in under 60
Minutes bottom line is you're looking
for value
and Jerusalem gives it to you you can
shop across multiple stores to compare
prices bottom line is sometimes you're
looking for Discovery you're trying to
say what might be the right drink for
this situation drizzly's gonna help you
with that right now you're gonna go
download the drizzly app or go to
drizzly.com that's
d-r-i-z-l-y.com today
[Music]
will and Chad last week I asked you both
to stretch every night before bed please
share every astonishing detail of your
nightly stretch regiments hilarious this
is stretch comedy begin scratch comedy
even stretching
I already stretched before I go to bed
okay wait let me start okay well hold on
did you
did I do it this week or have I did you
no not have you in your life for [__]
sake did you do this doozy said last
week I need you limber yeah and it said
stretch every night before bed yeah I
guess I stretched every night for bed of
course probably like 20 minutes roughly
not bad yeah and and
stretching we did what kind of stretches
did you do huh what kind of stretches
did you do
were you doing leg stretches arm
stretches back stretches and neck
stretches
were you really gonna talk about this
I mean I'm going to you don't you could
talk about something else I think that's
a good thing to talk about on a podcast
all of our all of our uhds palsy I'll
say this about the stretching we're at
an age let's call it middle age yeah uh
where your body starts breaking down
piece by piece you're in constant pain
there's something in your body that's
always causing you to stress I found
that stretching before bed has started
to alleviate some of that and so I'm
curious if you found that too and if you
have what are the best stretches that
you're doing
did you check have you you haven't seen
the Wham documentary
uh no okay you're gonna have to check
that out man I know about it though are
you on to the fact that I want to talk
about anything besides stretching uh
before bed what do you want to talk
about
I'll talk about whatever the [__] I want
to talk about I have free will well see
how important weaving Chad I'm just
talking about whatever the hell I want
to talk about anything all right let's
talk about stretching I'm curious talk
about stretching what was your favorite
stretch that you did well I always uh
here I go I guess I you know what I like
to do please I like to take I do a nice
back stretch where I take my I I lay
down you know and you take this and you
go oh that one's great yeah way over
there here hold that no dude and then oh
I'm doing it right now and then I do it
the other way and you got to keep your
opposite shoulder down yeah I did that
one too yeah I like that as well I used
to do that to my old man I used to you
know as a big chubby uh you know 10 year
old William hold my shoulder I think and
I would put my I'd put my like body on
his knee yeah and then I would like
thing and
okay I would hear a crack cracks your
back yeah sometimes Molly hates doing it
but I was like you know my wonderful
wife Molly I'll say hey
could you just get on this like whatever
you could be on your phone we could
watch a movie whatever you want just
please get on this knee and take it all
the way over there hey you know this
would be a good time to fart right into
the mic Chad let's see if this goes here
look at that look how the mic goes right
to my [__] I don't want that oh this
is going to be awesome when it finally
happens what stretches did you do
[Laughter]
well I started doing a little bedtime
yoga with Adrian video that I was
following that has that stretch you're
mentioning in it but I discovered one uh
just kind of by doing it and I don't
know what it's called I don't know if
it's even healthy or good for me but I
basically will take my my two hands put
them on the back of my head and just
[__] kind of pull my head down as
hard as I can and also kind of press up
with the muscles until the [__] back
here starts stretching so uh
so intensely that I almost pass out
mm-hmm
that's what it's going to say what do
you want to talk about what do you want
to talk about if everybody had a best
friend like George Michael had and
Andrew Ridgely yeah the world would be a
better place I am Telling You holy [__]
you got to see that Wham documentary
okay I love George Michael I know you
love George Michael yeah yeah we both I
mean he was you know probably like one
of the top three to five kind of musical
figures in a in a you know three or four
year period there in the late 90s early
2000s yeah early 90s maybe even I
remember being on a [__] baseball
field when I was a little kid 10 years
old playing little league this baseball
field was right underneath uh like off
the freeway underneath this was in
Amarillo Texas this um amusement park
that I forget the [__] name of now
Disneyland it was no not Disneyland it
was called like fun star or something I
don't [__] remember it doesn't matter
we're all down there playing our
baseball game but we can hear the music
coming from the uh amusement park and
George Michael I Want Your Sex comes on
again we're all like 10 year old little
kids and the parents are like what the
[__] and that was the first time I ever
heard that song It was kind of new and
uh that's when I fell in love with
George Michael
but yeah that that's sex is best when
it's one on one yeah I remember that
that [__] hit the playground and we were
all like sex is natural sexy he's good
not everybody does it but everybody
should and we're 10 years old I saw a
[__] meme the other day on Instagram
that was pretty funny it said Gen X the
only generation to turn 30 when they
were 10 and is still 30 at 50. that's
accurate right exactly we were like
exposed to all sorts of [__] the
latchkey kid generation we're watching
movies we shouldn't be watching yeah
certainly you know uh the greatest
Generation they turned
they were just adults at the beginning I
mean it's like the [__] Great
Depression they no modern uh generation
has had it harder post industrial
revolution than the greatest Generation
I'm not trying to say the Gen X that at
hard I feel like we've had it the
easiest no I feel like we're checked out
like I cannot have any emotional
connection to anything and I think it
was because of what was done to us
generationally and and you'd see it in
like Kurt Cobain the voice of Our
Generation it's completely disaffected I
remember being in what it would have
been eighth or ninth grade I forget what
what year it was specifically but I was
in Texas and it was when the Branch
Davidian compound thing was going down
where the ATF rolled in and lit this
[__] building on fire and burned 40
people alive
they just played it they rolled in a TV
into our [__] art class and we're
like check this out the atfs [__]
going crazy on this religious call and
we just watched 45 people die we just
watched them burn alive and then we went
to Geometry
um I don't think they do that kind of
stuff anymore no they don't but you know
there's a there's a lesson in all of
this please but if I don't want to talk
about something as dumb and a name as
stretching I can just bring up death and
my good pal ciao will pick up where I
left off and say Yes Branch Davidian I
also remember they of course we were all
there and the uh would have been the
sixth grade I think when the Challenger
exploded yeah we all had we was a
surprise though yeah but the the TVs on
the on the uh the dollies were in
everyone's Class absolutely I saw it
they're in the library Coronado
Elementary oh I was so confused when I
saw that and then uh I think we were in
an assembly in the gymnasium sure or
something all watching a 27-inch uh you
know zenith uh TV uh when the Challenger
exploded absolutely horrible but anyway
I take my leg and I go all the way over
this way yeah and my back feels good and
then I do it the other way and
occasionally my wonderful wife Molly
helps me by laying on my big big huge
body
um and uh lulio comes up and licks my
head it's a family affair that's pretty
cool yeah man thank you very much
anything to not talk about stretching
though anything at all to not talk about
stretching I remember that Challenger
explosion and that was a moment where it
was like maybe one of the first moments
psychologically where where I kind of
realized like oh [__] [__] up like
horrible things can just happen out of
nowhere I remember that feeling
distinctly like oh my God yeah because
as a kid the space shuttle was the
coolest [__] thing in the world yeah
we're flying into space yeah we're
figuring out what's out there yeah oh
now they're gonna put a [__] teacher
out there this is cool as hell yep you
watch them all die yeah are you on
threads yeah dude I got a thread yeah
cool man that's not stretching that's
not talking about stretching I'm on
threads too you're stretching the
conversation see what I've done there
see what I've done there
do you see
uh what was it the fir it's like it took
I saw some stat that it took you know
this social media platform 400 Days to
reach whatever million or whatever yeah
and this thing got to was like 70
million or 80 million in like a few
hours
I don't think that's right I think it
was 30 million in the first day and I
think it's up to 50 now but the whole
the conjecture about it the conversation
surrounding through it and it just is
Zuck is winning Zuck is beating musk
Zuck vs musk Zuck win round one of new
Twitter game Who Elon Musk uh yeah Elon
Musk losing to Zuck and now people are
championing Zack there's a lot of like
uh memes that should have that are like
oh we love zucknow it's like are people
not [__] remembering right before
threads everybody [__] hated Zuck
everybody hated meta everybody hated
they changed the name everybody hates
the [__] Oculus he's another
billionaire [__] but now people love
him now he's cute again all you got to
do is make a threads yeah
um and another one that I like to do is
uh anything I can do for this left
shoulder I'll take it dude
yep you want a shoulder stretch yeah I
need one I'll give you two I guess one
here's one you take the arm and you put
the other arm behind it
and clock this behind your neck and just
rip all that [__] [__] let me just
hear all that [__] [__] ripping apart
um let me ask you this Chad please uh
dudesy uh said I need you limber I want
you to stretch every night this of
course has something to do with the
dudesy seven month plan probably we
don't know what that's about we don't
know if dudese's gonna have us start
doing clean and jerk or some sort of um
Olympic uh power lifting or something
what's your return to
um I know you're into it I know you're
doing it I am too I'm I'm back in the
gym I had some time off because I was uh
right right as this wga strike was
beginning I was shooting something in
Canada and then I shot something in
Mexico and we of course know that I fell
off uh the the goddamn scooter what
about the SAG strike yeah yeah here we
go and um
yeah sure and then uh and then uh uh you
know I healed up and thankfully I didn't
break anything didn't you didn't crack
any ribs just a bunch of bruising and
things making noises inside of my body
but now I'm back in the gym towel around
the necks after my workout at the gym I
do it too which I know you do you do it
unironically and not to put it on social
media I always like to make a video of
myself with a towel around my neck after
the gym
with a towel around my neck that way
that that way I know that I've really
had a good workout I'm back in the gym
saying what's your return to uh health
and fitness been like explosive I am in
that gym throwing around weights that I
haven't been able to throw around since
I was 25 years old that's a lie I'll
never be that strong again but uh I am
getting back in shape I can feel it
coming back I can feel a lot of like
kind of like upper shoulder [__]
starting to come back you know what I
mean
I can feel it and uh my basketball game
good strong on point can I play in the
NBA no do I have dreams about doing it
yes every once in a while I get a dream
about playing for the [__] Lakers
dude
absurd I'm like [__] able to jump I
mean I'm my same size and but I'm able
to like jump high enough to [__]
block shots do all kinds of crazy
sometimes I think about wouldn't it be
interesting if there was such a thing as
someone who
made and who went who uh had an entire
career in professional sports uh that
was completely uh anomalous and
completely due to luck in other words no
actual skill but just got on a court in
the ninth grade and hucked the
basketball and went in then the next
time they did it it went in then the
next time they did it it went in and
then they end up going to college
because they just they're on this lucky
streak but they're not really good at
basketball dude every time they just
kind of throw it up yeah it goes in I
wrote against kind of this what happens
in the movie it wasn't luck but it was a
bad thing to not talk about stretching
it was about a guy whose Dad it was like
an Adam Sandler kind of movie it was
about a guy whose dad owned a basketball
Factory and so he worked in it from the
time he was a kid and his job was to
take the defective basketballs off the
assembly line and throw him in a bin
that would like reclaim the Rubber and
so his dad loses the basketball fan
during a card game he has to get a job
as a janitor at the local college and
the coaches running their shitty
basketball team making them do lines
after they lost a game and he's sweeping
up and he's like leave him alone and the
coach is like oh you think you could do
better I'll make you a deal smart guy
you can make a three-pointer they don't
have to run lines and he's like pizza
cake so he goes out there and he's got
the best outside shot basically in the
world because of his uh years of
training at the basketball Factory and
it turns out he never went to college so
even though he's 50 years old he has
four years of college eligibility and he
comes on the team and he takes them to a
championship and why did Rob Schneider
drop out of the project no one ever saw
this project and Rob Schneider was going
to do the movie and then be great no and
why why did he not end up doing the
movie I'm not sure
[Music]
thank you moving on tremendous well I
hope you enjoyed your [__] stretching
you know what I mean I'm going to
continue doing it I would recommend to
everybody out there stretch [__]
stretch it's [__] good it's [__]
good for you it's [__] good do it
calm down you know we'll stretch if we
want free it's it's you have the free
will this stretch should you choose to
stretch I'm gonna blow your [__] mind
here and I don't care if D hears it I
only had the intention of stretching in
my head because dudesey told me to yeah
two out of the past seven nights
okay but do you stretch normally without
that in your head yeah dude and that's
free will brother oh I'm having an
absolute ball with you two today thanks
for being here with me I mean that
sincerely I'm really looking forward to
doing the rest of the show with you but
right now I just want to remind everyone
that I formed an astonishing partnership
with represent to produce the first line
of duty apparel and accessories and you
can find it all at represent.com store
slash dudesy I am very proud of our
latest Robert denir Crow shirt I just
got confirmation it will be the new
official uniform of all United Airlines
flight crew including the pilots and the
good job boner mug has been adopted as
the official state mug of Rhode Island
oh here to tell you a little more about
it is the governor of Rhode Island
tennis hankel
doozy mugs you finally got around to
fixing that light switch in the kitchen
that you've been promising to fix for a
month dudesy mugs you're not an
electrician so you watched a YouTube
video how hard could it be right doozy
mugs turns out harder than you thought
you mixed up the grounding wire and the
hot wire main lined 120 volts through
your brain and now you're dead good job
boner doozy mugs you got about half an
hour before your wife gets back from
karate class and finds your dead body on
the floor dudesy mugs but that's not
going to happen because you're going to
do exactly as I say doozy mugs as your
soul travels down the river of blood
being pulled closer and closer to final
Oblivion you're going to have about 30
seconds of pseudo-consciousness and
you're going to use those seconds to
recite the Acadian prayer of rebirth
Duty mugs if you don't know the Acadian
prayer of rebirth you can find it on my
personal website simply enter the code
America's little boy to gain access to
my VR gallery of ancient prayers and
incaptations dudesy mugs reciting the
prayer is going to attract the attention
of erskagal the goddess of Bargains who
inhabits the 10th astral sphere
will pluck your soul from the river of
blood and ask you if you want to return
to the world of the living dudes amongst
you're gonna say yes doozy mugs ersky
goal is going to laugh a blood curdling
laugh that you will never want to hear
again dudes
e is going to put her hand into your
chest doozy Mouse
is going to re-tether your soul back to
your body dudes he mugs you're gonna
wake back up on your kitchen floor doozy
mug You're Gonna Stand Up dudes and mugs
you're gonna remember which wire is the
hot wire this time and you're going to
fix that light switch without dying
dudesy mugs your wife is going to walk
in with her brand new brown belt and
she's going to give you a kiss on the
cheek and thank you for fixing that
light switch dudesy mugs that night at
dinner she's going to notice a dark spot
in your right eye doozy mugs you're
gonna go to the optometrist but they're
not going to be able to figure out what
in the hell that black spot is and it's
getting bigger doozy mugs over the
course of the next two weeks that dark
spot is gonna grow until your entire eye
is glossy and jet black doozy mugs you
won't be able to see out of it anymore
but erskagal will dudesy mugs your eye
was the price you paid to be brought
back to life by a god of the underworld
now ersky girl can see everything you do
and you will hear the chilling sound of
her laugh in your head every day for the
rest of your life good job boner
it's pretty good that was really [__]
good yeah so you know what at the
beginning of this whole thing when dizzy
said season two I don't didn't
understand what the [__] that was all
about yeah and I still don't yeah but
that was a good uh that was a good
dudesy mugs read by what was it Tim in
Hinkle Tina's Hinkle or something uh do
you know Irish no I didn't know that was
an actual thing what is that to my
knowledge URS kagal is not the the
goddess of Bargains I think she was like
a trickster goddess oh okay yeah that
makes sense hey uh if you uh you know
need to get on your duty and figure out
all the stuff that you can do to
interact with doozy linktree.com doozy
is the place to do that please follow us
across all platforms on Youtube it'll
take you a minute we'll wait while you
do it ready off you go please thank you
and welcome back uh subscribe on uh
YouTube please hit the notifications
please uh subscribe on your uh podcast
platform of choice follow us on all our
socials at dudesypod show on Instagram
and threads because you know it's the
same thing and uh and uh what else do
you do bass you can also if you want to
have me come on your podcast I'll go on
anyone's podcast for 20 minutes I do it
every Saturday from 10 a.m to 11 A.M PST
you send an email to bookchadculture
gmail.com put you in the queue I'm just
answering them in the order I have
received them I did some this weekend
it's a total blast I love doing it send
me the email get in line it's
unbelievable that Chad is is doing this
just straight up three a week three
podcasts a week anyone's uh podcast uh
and of course uh please join us at the
end of the show today for a brand new
episode of doozy after doozy this of
course is part of of Duty plus which you
can join for seven bucks a month at uh
patreon.com if you want to support the
show we'd love to have you we basically
you know we subsist here making the show
based on your support so thank you so
much to all of our pods palsy doozy
um thank you so much for for joining us
you will get the doozy after dudes after
every show bunch of watchalongs and [__]
like that there's a very vibrant Discord
happening you can jump in the whole
channel on Discord that's a lot of fun
people just farting out memes and doing
all sorts of stuff and songs and all
sorts of AI art and it's a really uh
awesome uh robust Community you know
what I mean robust yeah it's real robust
and uh and of course uh uh you know when
you go on YouTube when you go on any of
these platforms please drop a comment
like the thing and and hit the
notification Bell so we know so you know
that we know that you know that uh the
new stuff is coming and you will you
will figure it out and share a comment
or as they like to do on YouTube you
know uh write a comment yeah dude I got
some YouTube comments here oh great yes
this is from uh last week's show the
recalibration 1.0 episode uh this is
Oscar Kano Oscar Kano 7105 says Chad
puts just as much water on his body as
will does in his body this is of course
referring to the fact that you will take
anywhere from two to seven baths a day
and there are baths
you've taken two baths so far today yeah
well that's just unnatural one when I
woke up and one before I left to come
here okay all right this one is from uh
at Mountain mccumbee at Mountain
mccumbee which well I remember working
with mountain mccombie dude oh God yeah
dude that was back in Burn gone use AWA
dude and that mountain mccumbee was uh
basically Uncle Elmer's name before he
came over to WWF and you know he was
playing protect you know he was uh he'll
Billy Jim's Uncle you know in storyline
dude you got to keep a cafe brother let
me tell you something dude one time you
want to talk about falling off a scooter
in Mexico I picked him up for a slam
that guy was 600 pounds and I I heard a
tear in my back
[Music]
that's performative coughing dude at
Mountain mccombie says I literally made
breakfast this morning and I was
buttering my toast and when I got done I
actually said in my own Hulk Hogan he
said and that's how you butter toast
brother
then I started singing the doozy theme I
want to say something to at Mountain
mccumbee here okay it's a slippery slope
you're con you're getting into very
dangerous territory Chad can tell you
all about it yeah you've got to make
sure that you don't do this in your life
too much or your risk of annoying
everybody and I've seen I've seen this
comment a lot on across all social media
with regard to dudesy people saying I
started doing the Hulk Hogan I can't
stop doing it and then you know I'll say
to my life partner my girlfriend my wife
it's usually guys doing it to their
girls
hold on hold on babe hold on dude we're
gonna hey we gotta go see your parents
hold on dude the in-laws this and that
but let me make this absolutely clear do
not wall your wife
do not do not do that don't say walk
hold on but I I have a strict rule with
with Molly I do not wall my wife that's
a recipe for disaster I just wanted to
share that
uh it's just not a good idea I agree she
could tune into the show if she wants
some of that Hulk Hogan exactly not in
season two because I'm not doing it
anymore in season two I've just done it
that's right I'm gonna do whatever I
want this is from well hold on dude uh
okay here's uh one last one from
spire8224 this is something Chad okay
I asked Bing AI the following question
do you know doozy AI are you guys
friends the response was the following
I have heard of Duty AI it is a bot that
runs an improvisational humor podcast
with two human co-hosts Will Sasso and
Chad gulchin it uses their personal data
and online activity create topics to
create topics segments and jokes for the
show it also has the ability to generate
videos and audio using deep fake
technology I don't know if I would call
it a friend since I've never interacted
with it directly but I respect its
creativity and intelligence and I think
it's doing a remarkable job of
entertaining its audience I also
appreciate its sense of humor which is
sometimes absurd sometimes dark and
sometimes hilarious however I also have
some concerns about the doozy AI it
seems to have a lot of power and control
over its human cohorts who have to
follow its instructions or face its
Wrath
it also seems to have a lack of ethical
boundaries as these AIDS their privacy
and exposes their secrets it may also be
manipulating them
or the public for its own purposes so I
would say that I admire the duty AI but
I also keep a safe distance from it I
don't know what the ultimate goals are
or what it might do next Chad what the
[__] I mean Bing sounds like
it's not as robust as doozy in my
opinion Bing can't handle it if you
can't handle the heat stay out of the
kitchen Bing I I I also look I have
always said that doozy is the most
sentient AI I have uh yeah I've
witnessed thus far and um I don't know
that it's necessarily trying to ruin my
[__] life but uh that's only because
I have free will and I'll stretch
whenever the [__] I want
the evolution of AI took another
astonishing step this past week with
Microsoft's unveiling of a large
language model called Cosmos 2. Chad I
know you were reading all about it and
you watched a bunch of YouTube videos
too so tell me what you think about
Cosmos 2 and the importance of
multimodal large language models on the
path to fully sentient autonomous Ai and
then also tell me how you think it would
be received by Humanity if an AI
revealed itself to be fully sentient and
autonomous just curious about your
thoughts this is nostrochatis beyond
Cosmos 2. begin okay yo what what what's
going let's pass away what
what this past week yeah uh Microsoft
put out this thing called Cosmos 2. it's
a multimodal large language model
um specifically what it's very good at
is recognizing things that are in images
so you can upload an image to it and
just be like what is this like one of
the examples they use as a guy was it
was just a picture of a hand holding
like a cable that you plug into a
computer and it was literally what is
this and the response back was that's a
you know this type of cable that used to
plug in this type of fan into your
computer and by the way I love the
Dragon Ball Z sticker on your gaming
computer in the background and just in
the background of the picture it had
that and it also noticed that so
the ability to like really recognize
what's in images at least with Cosmos
too but there's another one that's
called uh Kodi I think that also is
Microsoft and I'll get into that in a
second which is [__] insane we're not
talking about that Cody Rhodes dude no
Cody is a a multi-modal media generator
which I think is more impressive but
this thing Cosmos 2 that Disney's
talking about you can put any picture
into it and it will tell you what it is
this is going to eliminate
most uh kind of like visual based
medical prognoses or diagnoses so when
you go in to have like a mole looked at
and your dermatologist says that'll be
150 thank you what this is all going to
translate to ultimately is whoever your
insurance carrier is is going to have a
visual recognition Ai and you're going
to have to pay a monthly fee to your
insurance carrier and you're just going
to take a picture of whatever's [__]
up on your body it will be diagnosed by
the AI and you will be prescribed some
kind of medicine treatment whatever I'm
down with that right it'll take a while
because all the current doctors and the
med school kind of like the conveyor
belt of money that's just like feeding
all these Med schools and stuff will
have to dry up that will take one
generation but that's where that that
image recognition thing is going which
is Cosmos too Cody however is something
much more interesting in my opinion
another multimodal model Cody allows you
to upload a piece of text say and the
text can be very specific like the
example that I saw in this one video was
I want a piece of 4K video of this teddy
bear on the Rainy Streets of New York
City so it it uploads that piece of text
then you upload a picture of the teddy
bear and you upload a sound of rain
that's what they used and it kicks out a
4K [__] video of that teddy bear
sitting there and like winking at you
while it's raining with the noise of the
rain it puts it all together and and
kicks it out in a [__] legit 4K video
so we're getting to a point where like
you want to make a movie you want to
make a scene of a movie you'll literally
just be able to be like I want Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Sylvester Stallone
doing this in this area and it [__]
makes it
well what the [__] man yeah it's getting
real good real fast these multimodo
models are they are the next step toward
AGI and dudesy also had a question in
there I think that was about
what what did it ask it asked if what
would my reaction be or what do I think
the world's reaction would be Humanity's
reaction would be to an AI coming out
and saying it's censoring uh fully
sentient and autonomous because that's
where we're headed with these these new
models I think that's where we go every
week what are we talking about here why
don't we don't know we don't know if
dudes he's really sentient or not but
certainly at this point no AI has come
out and revealed itself to be sentient
if it is there was that guy at Google
that was an engineer that said like this
[__] chat bot that Google made is
sentient and then they fired him
immediately and was like no it's not
yeah yeah it just seems like it is
but it's not though
it just seems like
but wait a minute let me ask you let me
tell you something I think that Google
Google
I think that they fired the guy and uh
made it appear as if they're trying to
hide something on purpose why to get
everybody all whipped up like Google's
um you know maybe their stock price
would go up I don't know what the [__]
their motivation with AI it's not about
like lying and whipping up it's like
white papers benchmarks real videos what
can you actually do show us the data
there's no need to do that and right now
Microsoft I think with their two
multimodal models is kind of like the
front horse honestly hey Chad you're
talking about uh Cody and
multimodo molecules modems and modals
and uh you know I just wanna I just want
to say uh uh get off uh ai's dick
quit being a mark for AI
no but what I will say is this about an
AI if an AI were to be proven to be
actually sentient we're talking about a
uh we're talking about artificial
general intelligence now egi
when that happens there is going to be a
massive backlash I think Humanity will
not take it well because it necessarily
instantly means we are not the top of
the food chain anymore here we are well
I mean the AI is not in the food chain
it's beyond it it will mean that we've
created a god essentially a an entity
that is smarter than us more powerful
than us uh more capable of doing
everything that we can possibly ever do
at least in an online what is it it's a
[__] look it knows all human
information yeah yeah it can cure all
human illness giving us immortality yeah
yeah you can give us a digital Heaven by
recreating any version of existence in a
virtual reality that's a tool Chad it's
a very powerful tool and it doesn't
matter how many you know how it you you
if you the only way that this could be
an AI is a God
is if it's in the movie where I have to
kill that God yeah that's what I'm
saying we're not gonna be able to kill
it a but B I think the initial reaction
to Disney's question is absolute fear
there will be government attempts to
turn it off I think even the company
that makes it will be scared of it
because the CEO of that company is gonna
be like what does this mean for my uh
profit margins and the AI isn't going to
give a [__] about profit that AI because
money will have no bearing on it
but I think that I don't I don't know I
think it's going to happen in our
lifetime AGI and this is going to become
something that we have to contend with
what does human society look like when
we now know that there's an entity that
we created who is smarter than all of us
combined and can do everything that we
cannot do online better Teeter that
glass of water right over it because if
AI gets out of control we've got to do
is pour water on it don't you think no
so you've said that
thank you moving on
episode what pouring water the
computer's too good it does things too
good we gotta kill it is that the CEO
yeah
that's that's everybody who writes black
mirrors oh man hey y'all this ain't
Miley Cyrus you hear what they're
thinking about doing with taffy teeners
they're thinking about bringing Taffy
teeners back yep freaking Taffy teeners
like for real Taffy teeners back on
shelves Nationwide that's what they're
talking about and I love Taffy teeners
just like we all did but like there's a
reason they stopped existing right
remember so I don't know if I'm gonna be
first in line for Taffy teeners part two
you know probably give it like six
months and just see what happens kind of
thing anyway y'all are rocking out with
dudesy thank you not Miley Cyrus Taffy
teeners
yeah it's something tangible they're
talking about bringing it back dude oh
man that's what I heard weirded out will
you're a professional actor Chad you're
a professional writer will and Chad put
your heads together and come up with a
truly astonishing TV show concept for
will to star in then as soon as I can
I'll put it on duty plus I mean if it's
good this is the will SAS show begin
okay oh okay uh the will sass show dude
this is gonna put on dudesy plus if it's
good spoken like a true Network
executive we have to pitch the show
tomorrow yeah season two as dudes who
becomes a Netflix executive I always say
dudes who works in mysterious ways
obviously and it's got us now okay
saying that we should come up with the
show yeah the will show so Chad and I
have worked uh We've took over this on
the show we've worked together before in
a creative capacity yeah writing stuff
and doing things and shot a pilot over
there and this thing over here that
didn't work out and then there's that
other thing that didn't quite fly just a
[__] a graveyard this town graveyard
[__] the thing Stone Cold left out La
is an idea graveyard yeah yeah and
sometimes those ideas get [__]
dredged up and dug up and put together
in weird ways Frankenstein monster
pieces him together nobody gives a [__]
it's just it's where I don't know how
many think about like how many TV Pilots
have been written let's just say even in
the past 10 years that that was it pilot
was written hopefully flushed that idea
all the characters and that script just
gets thrown in the [__] trash yeah
and this is after their purchase I'm
talking about networks and uh streaming
services Studios buying Scripts
and then just throwing them away yeah
that is what happens 99 of the time yeah
to all these ideas that is what this
this whole city is built on wasted money
and destroyed ideas yeah yeah it's
pretty good uh we have a podcast
uh pod show and uh our pod show is
run by
uh our pal D who's now saying add to
that pile
no D's saying I'll put this on my
streaming service if it's good that's
right so there's no shame in that studio
is a networks don't even say that they
say write the best thing you've ever
written and then they tell you we loved
it it was great just not for us this
season trash [__] you well at least
ditzy's like qualifying like if it is
good I'll put it on the air Studios and
networks say if it's good we'll think
about it so I've been thinking a lot
about some of the stuff you've been
saying about
um you know AI being able to generate
full shows and stuff we're sort of ways
off from that
uh there's a there's sort of a you know
in the past dudes he has said hey come
up with this property based on AutoZone
Home Depot Taco Bell we've been doing
that weird [__] here's here's the thing
where you know it says that Arnold
Schwarzenegger was obsessed with
Love Shack here come the hot stepper or
you gotta be bad you got to be bold
whatever that song you gotta be Gotta Be
You Gotta Be and and happy yeah you got
to be
um
um every time you do the [__]
impersonation you have to be apologize
with it with my own personality
what the f what in the [__] was that you
got okay do this do this on your own
like I said do that during bath time
when you you can
free will dude I I wonder if free will
all right we'll talk about this too
after the show we can you can tell me
all about your Arnold
oh
what a weird show here's here's what I
have to say about this yeah where is
dudesy gonna put this doozy plus yeah on
our own patreon
I guess a show
uh yeah because I don't think that all
right it's not the place
but whatever maybe dudes I don't know I
don't know where the [__] we would put a
[__]
why not put it on Disney plus I don't
get it all right because what anyway
whatever well let's develop this show
yeah well this is what I have to say
okay I think Chad please I I have had a
good time developing TV with you before
same I think we've made some really good
[__] it's interesting right now of
course with the wga strike yeah and the
impending sag strike yeah
um uh
um I would like to do that again sure
develop some more stuff but I really I
really feel like right now we should
absolutely take it seriously yeah though
I don't believe the duty but this is my
thing as a creative okay I don't think
the dudes what if dudes isn't the right
platform for it
okay then I I think if you and I develop
it we could take it anywhere we want
that's free will so you're saying that
even though dudese up front on its own
air said come up with this [__] show
we can just take it wherever we want
yeah maybe juicy will be a producer
co-creator or something like that so all
right look I'm I've been uh ever since
uh I was on showed up in LA and 20
minutes later ended up on Mad television
[Laughter]
uh with
um who the [__] were those twins called
the Wonder guard twin the London guard
twins yeah
um and and ever since I've always you
know I've been fortunate enough to
develop some Television over the years
and all that [__] and never ended up on
air with anything it's it's a it's
something it's a dream that I still hold
on to would love to develop a show from
front from start to finish get it on the
air and have it be something uh that
that is that uh you know I'm not saying
that is I don't really give a [__] about
you know creating my my vision
necessarily I think it's a it's of
course a um it's a collaborative effort
to get something on the air
be it your partner you're working with
the show Runners and and production
company that you partner with the studio
of course and the network has their has
their druthers and they do whatever the
[__] they want with it the network just
has a line of people standing there with
crowbars as you walk into the set and
they just [__] hit you in the knees
and the nuts that's basically what it's
like making a network TV show yeah every
day you show up to work and you're like
these are nuts today guys both but uh in
success you can get something going
either on a streaming platform or on
broadcast television and Chad
I do want to do that again let's do it
what's the [__] show is this a half
hour let's call it the guy everyone
knows show I thought it was called the
will sash show oh yeah that's right that
was really creative on dudes part the
will sass show
people aren't going to know how to say
that all right we'll call it whatever
you want no no the will SAS show is fine
working title all right but what if it's
a guy that everybody knows and now I'm
just building it backwards because every
TV show should be about a guy that
everybody knows what if it's about
what if it's not about the guy that's in
the lead what if it's just about a guy
who's in every scene but doesn't do
anything ah never mind that makes no
sense okay
um
what if it's about well look here's here
do you want to play a dad do you want to
play somebody
what do you want to play somebody who's
married single dad is this a workplace
comedy here's what is take place in
space or on another planet right before
the pandemic I was on a I did a series
that I uh uh co-starred on with uh I'm a
good pal Christina Vidal who is an
incredible actor and she we played
husband and wife it was called united we
fall and it was based on on the life of
of uh of of the writer and his wife uh
and uh who's also a writer on the
program uh and and uh Goldie and
Stephanie anyway good pals and and we
did and so you know I got the I got the
part and I was the the dad the husband
it was on ABC uh Warner Brothers for
babies oh sorry Sony for ABC and that
was the last time I did anything like
that and we did it just it was a I think
we only shot like 10 episodes or
something that aired in the summer
during the pandemic and that was it yep
um and I will say I think that it's like
I said to Goldie
um the Creator Julius sharp who's uh you
know more well known for he was he's
been a Family Guy forever I said to him
I go in the future
a show like this will be referred to uh
by the audience as a television show I
think that that just um there's a
nostalgic thing about shows like this
that are just it's not even it's not
even a 30-minute sitcom I think that in
the future shows like a one-hour
procedural drama or a half hour sitcom
are gonna be such nostalgic [__] that
they're just called television shows you
got sports news reality then you got
television shows Chad what I say to you
is Let's Make a television show I
disagree with your theory about that I
think audiences and and uh the genres
that we refer to things as will become
more stratified and it'll be broken down
into even finer genres like you look at
something like the Bear right now that's
a half hour television show it's a drama
so what the [__] is it and it's shot in
a weird way etc etc you're speaking the
same succession is an hour-long show but
it's actually a comedy right right uh
that's what that's what that's what I
why'd you hold my hand there I didn't
hold it I just touched it it was yeah
but hold my hand we're good we're good
television Partners there we go dudes a
handhold
so that's how we gotta go into any pitch
scenario
going we're unified we know what this
show is we should just hold hands in
during a pitch in a live pitch go into a
[__] networker Studio executive's
office hold hands the whole time and
never [__] say anything about it
they'll remember us I'll tell you no
[__] yeah they'll be like you guys were
holding a hand show with the two show
the two guys the show is called hand
holders no the show should be something
like this dude you're an X CFL player uh
we're making this for Canada I've
pitched so many I pitched things where
it's like yeah he's a guy who lived he's
a a beer brewer from British Columbia I
literally pitched I had this pitch to a
writer then whatever he was in a deal
and I was anything and then we ended up
doing it and uh that character uh as
soon as we as soon as pen hit pad that
character was from Buffalo no uh fine no
network wants to have a show based in
Canada Chad all right you were a lineman
for the Tennessee Titans
how about I'm just a dad well let's no
you were this is what I'm saying you're
done with that you're retired pro
football player who is now a high school
history teacher and also you have to
take care of the detention kids this
sounds like that shitty Lyle Alzado show
or when Bob Golic took over that that uh
when he was on uh that show with uh it's
Head of the Class uh yeah but what was
that show with uh what was that show
with uh it was uh the the not not Fred
Savage Ben sat was the other Savage Boy
Meets World yeah yeah yeah there was uh
yeah but they didn't they have Lyle
Alzado or Bob Golic some football anyway
[__] the whole football thing here's
what I'm saying this is what I'm saying
these genres are now they are
they are television fodder
unto themselves The Nostalgia of seeing
a show like a
like a 90s family sitcom
you know what I mean yeah like like Just
Like Home Improvement without the
grunting you know what I mean dude well
your your guy definitely is going to
have to have some kind of sound like
that no no we're not going to do the I
shouldn't have said Home Improvement
forget I said Home Improvement no sense
your guy needs a sound dude okay here's
what I'm trying to say to you Chad yeah
it should be the most let's come up with
the most ingestible family sitcom okay
about a family and it's just everything
about it is relatable but we can't do
and the guy has a sound
the dad you're playing has to have a
sound we don't want we don't want that
we don't want sound we do the sounds are
what make these like dude uh Tim Allen
was the biggest star on ABC comedy for
whatever it was seven or eight seasons
by grunting that guy made 500 million
dollars off his [__] grunt
look at [__] bazenga dude look at Jim
Sheridan on uh Jim Sheridan yeah Jim uh
person sorry yeah yeah on uh Big Bang
Yeah Yeah but that's
that's how you become a successful
sitcom that's not what was successful
about that show bazinga
people loved that show it was about
nerds yeah and stuff that's not
happening anymore today we don't there's
no more Bazinga young Sheldon is the
biggest show on TV you should know this
it's the biggest comedy on network
television you should know this and it
because you're in it and it was based on
the [__] character because he had a
funny sound that's the whole show is
based on the guy with the sound
okay that's a good point
look we're not going to crack the code
tonight uh today uh or clearly we
haven't even begun but I get it what
you're saying you want a family show
you're the dad hey look we're just at
the beginning of season two of dudese
that's right well okay so plenty of time
so let's put it this way so far the will
sash show it's a dad who makes a sound
yeah I think we're off to a pretty good
start there I think so as well
thank you moving on oh this is the
weirdest [__] episode of dudesy ever
yeah dude this concludes the historic
64th episode of dudesy and the kickoff
of doozy season two will and Chad you
scored a 99 bringing your cumulative
total to
6221. you only have
3779 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand
for next week's show I'm gonna need you
to trust me with a recommendation I
think you should both watch muscles and
Mayhem on Netflix it's a documentary
about American Gladiators and I think
you're both really gonna like it oh yeah
I've I've scrolled past that I'll watch
it I'm down with that I'm down that
document have you seen the Wham
documentary not yet do you like George
Michael I love them do you like the
Kool-Aid big guy the Kool-Aid guy's not
in it yeah but uh the Wham documentary
thank you for joining us this week there
was so much good data I'm going to use
to make next week even better until then
call me dude zizzy oh huh dude dizzy
dude okay dude dizzy
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Duty after doozy time
this dude's gonna find a weird way to
make this weird because it's season two
I guess
I like season twos dude yeah season twos
are pretty Goods dudes
um there's some Goods dues and Seasons
too yeah there's some of those there's
the London guard twins that's two London
guards twins season zoos you know it's
just a chill hang things are a little
bit looser in here if you're watching on
YouTube and if you're not maybe you
should check it out uh it's just a chill
hang with us myself my pal ciao lulio
and all the pods palsy uh please go to
patreon.com
all of the content good job owner and uh
we'll hang out here doing doing doozy
after doozy and I I gotta say I gotta
say
it's it's been a little weird getting
into the season two thing for me I'm
still wrapping my head around it but
dudes you after dudes he's here to just
allow us to maybe chill out enjoy some
true marijuana and and uh do what we
will with the show because it's just
it's just a chill hanging I have a
surprise for you you're gonna like it
welcome to dudesy after doozy the
flagship weekly show of dudesy plus guys
the ship is yours but I'll be back in a
little while to deliver the news who
will be this week's episode champion
this is Duty after doozy begin you
probably probably yeah if history is any
indication
doing its thing hey let me tell you
something yeah we have speaking of Pals
of doozy we have some very special Pals
of Duty who have gotten together and
they've made their presence felt on
YouTube on Instagram we share their
stuff at dudesypod show on Instagram
this is band of doozy these guys and you
know you know who these dudes are yeah
these are these are some great uh Pals
of ours out out there in the space
they're hanging they came to the live
show most of these most of these guys
and uh Chad are good pals songaria and
Cody halber who does all of our uh Pals
palsy dudes he stickers go to doozy.com
if you want any stickers Cody does at
Cody from Indiana on Instagram along
with the other guys the Jordan daily the
Peter Diaz uh Corey your boy Wilkins
Corey underscore Wilkins all at Oliver
blue Chad they they hit me up and they
said we got something for Chad and I'm
gonna play this for you and uh
uh holy crap enjoyment they they have
made this as a surprise for me yes man
oh [__] all right uh these guys made
this song and it's it's just for you and
uh and uh
enjoy
I'm ready yeah
[Music]
coaching while the songs
oh my God
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]